[Music]
foreign
territories did I Crush in Bangladesh I
got like 13 Bangladeshi kids bro but
that's that's it it's all micro targeted
now and so like just how even a movie's
engineered and they're so disingenuous
too because at the end of the day like
even a studio everything's already
pre-financed right they got letters of
credit they got up this they got that
they're throwing up a few million in cap
funding or something right it's so
risk-averse it's ridiculous what's your
biggest what's your biggest heartbreak
in in in in the film industry which the
thing that's hurt the most all right so
Hollywood I tell people is like watching
someone you love get by someone you hate
so
I mean there's a couple of them I mean
uh
you know the big one is like suicide
squad that [__] that [__] broke me that
handed me my ass how so
uh
come right off Fury right had had the
town in my hand could have done anything
and I did do anything and you know go on
this journey with it and the same thing
like like authentic truthful let's do
all the rehearsal let's really get in
each other's Souls let's create this
amazing collaborative thing right and
then
I dropped my director cut you know your
10-week assemb it's a [__] assembly
of 10 weeks for a movie that big come on
you know and
Deadpool opened right and then they
never tested Batman vs Superman so so
they put the movie out there and they
never did a test and they they
were expecting a different result and
then they got hammered by all the
critics and then it's like okay
we're going to turn David Ayers dark
Soulful movie into a [__] comedy now
I became the bad guy narratively oh it
was a tough director he's hard to work
with or this or that right because as
they're [__] you you were like stop
[__] yeah and as in the but the
producers themselves are like
like producer Studio people Executives
I'm not calling anybody out because
we're all like at the end of the day
like
it's [__] business right yeah I get
it
um but
The Narrative that like Oh I'm a hard
I'm hard to work with and I'm the
problem only puts more value and equity
in their career and and that's kind of
like what my path has been like I wrote
the first fast and furious man when I
when I got that script that [__] was set
in New York it was all Italian kids
right I went to stuber Scott stuber who
ran um it was running uh Universal at
the time
who hired me I'm like bro I'm not going
to take it unless I can set it in LA and
make it look like the people I know in
LA right so then I started like writing
in uh people of color and writing in the
street stuff and writing in the culture
and and no one knew [__] about street
racing at the time and I went to like a
shop in the valley met with like the
first guys that were doing the hacking
of the fuel curves for the injectors and
stuff like that and they just figured it
out and they're showing and I'm like oh
[__] yeah I'm gonna put that in the
movie you know like
it's what you do man and and biggest
franchise in Hollywood I don't know any
of it I don't know really I got nothing
to show for it nothing because of the
way the business works right and the
narrative is I didn't do [__] right so
it's like
people hijack narratives control
narratives create narratives to empower
themselves right and and because I was
always an outsider and because like
like I don't go to the [__] parties
right I don't go to the meals I don't do
any of that stuff yeah the people that
did were able to control managed
narratives because they're socializing
that part of the problem I was never
socializing that part of the problem so
I was always like like the dark creative
dude beware you know and and now it's
like okay great [__] all the middlemen
right
I get it it's up to me I gotta
self-rescue right I can [__] whine
about getting shot at and all the rounds
I've taken over my career I gotta
self-rescue and I gotta create an
ecology where it's safe for me to be
creative and that's it and that's what
I'm doing how do you do that
access to money people access to
decision makers
um just so many layers of decision
makers who has the actual green light
Authority right how do you get a
relationship with someone with that
Authority do you feel like there's
people out there that are that that
recognize this [__] good handful yeah
handful because I think everybody
recognizes what's good but your ability
to execute something good is not really
there but you come out like you you do
Harsh Times end of watching fear like
what the [__] is anybody gonna like how
are these people taking your movie away
from you like like how how is there a
movie yeah but but somebody somebody
knows what what the real score is there
but it's like
they never tested my cut and the thing
is I have it I [__] have a copy of it
right and if I didn't oh my God because
everyone I've shown the cut has the same
reaction rage yeah like this is the
movie we wanted why didn't we get this
WOW right wow and and and then like I'm
such a [__] bro about all this stuff
but like I've seen that like release the
air cut I've seen that on like what can
that get released I mean would you want
it to be released it's it's like
Schrodinger's cut now it's almost like
is it more legendary to see it or more
legendary to not see it yeah like I
talked to James gone and look they got
their own he's trying to figure it out
loud and you know it's it's possible but
they want to get some scores on the
board first yeah yeah
um I have I could show people I could
you know like but
it's it's tough because it's like it's I
want to [__] move on from and I want
to heal from it you know and it pisses
me off because like like dude I was
coming off Fury yeah right yeah and
during a time during Suicide Squad when
the dailies were coming in people are
like oh [__] maybe air is going to take
over DC yeah and there's all those Game
of Thrones in there the palace politics
were insane right and the [__] that was
really going on
bro all right okay you know and then and
then they're shooting at me and every
time you know the new movie comes out a
new movie would come out in this space
the Press would come at me again
right over like
like that's what became so [__] up is
I became a talking point inside of the
marketing for these other projects in a
negative way and I'm sitting there like
what is happening you know it's like
it's
I remember talking to people like do
what you know like talking to Kevin
Vance and yeah and and and Sensei and
and and you know and then like I mean
because that process of making that
movie sounds [__] righteous and
[__] like everybody was really
putting in Joel and and will and all
that
I mean so let me ask you now like do you
do you wish you would never do you wish
you had never done it like because
you're also somebody who's like like the
pain in the lumps is also what [__]
defines you and gets you where like
you're always [__] forward moving
like yeah dude I I remember in the the
fury press tour being in in uh some
[__] room and some fancy-ass [__]
hotel
and and and you were you were meeting I
mean you probably can't [__] talk
about you you were meeting like a very
famous actor and and and and and
horribly unlucky to you guys you got
seated right next to like me and Shia
and Mike and and you're meeting about
suicide squad and Shia like got up and
he's like he's like what the [__] G why
are you doing this [__] movie [__]
you for even wanting to be in this movie
you're throwing it away bro don't
[__] do it bro and like uh should
listen to him dude I remember seeing
like thinking I remember being like shy
dude like what are you [__] because for
me at that point anybody said anything
about it about you met like dude I'll
kill like you know but it was shy and I
was like what are you doing bro I don't
know I I it's like like you said it's a
wildly successful movie and it's like
and now you're in this like place in
your life I mean how do you look back on
that like I understand the pain that
it's caused you but but but like do you
wish I mean I don't even know what that
[__] does anyways I'm ambivalent man
like like
part of like I have to own my life and I
have to own my journey in in my
experiences right
it
you know it's like like Gone With the
Wind and there's that moment where
Scarlett or Hera is like you know I will
never go hungry again you know like that
taught me I have to have control over my
work I have to have control over my work
and I won't get in a situation where I
don't have that control over again
because
they will strap a bomb to your back and
bury you in a [__] crater they don't
give a [__] like
little rip your guts out if it serves
their empire like for-profit corporate
speech right quarterly oh if this
quarter we were able to save on payroll
by firing people and this movie made a
profit and we sold secondary that's all
they [__] care about I don't care
about you everyone's disposable man like
and it's like
taking me kind of coming to terms with
the reality of Hollywood
you know and what it is and it's it's
been so confusing and then at the same
time this is the business that's changed
my life this business has built my house
this is a business that's given me these
opportunities to travel the world and
see things and meet people you know so
so it's tough It's like you know yeah
you get petted and slapped you know
sometimes at the same time dude that's
[__] great that's so funny
[Music]
all right
hey what's going on everybody it's John
and Bam Bam the dog uh first on behalf
of both of us and everybody from the
real ones team I just want to sincerely
thank you guys for for tuning in the
folks that I bring on the show they're
family to me and uh being able to tell
their stories and bringing you into
their world is something I'm I'm just
super proud of and uh again grateful
that you guys tune in we've decided we
want to take things just a step further
it's a patreon community and basically
what that means is if you become a part
of this community look I already board
Bam Bam if you want to become a part of
this community you're going to be able
to hear episodes early and all that ad
free and all that good stuff but there's
all this behind the scenes footage all
this stuff that we've shot that really
brings you into the folks that we've had
on the show really brings you into their
world live chats with me and the folks
that I bring on the show to talk about
their world talk about the issues that
they're dealing with but their triumphs
and their tragedies just go to patreon
slash real ones on this website that you
see right there right on the screen
that's right in front of you this whole
idea idea was something about building
bridges and and bringing people together
and bringing folks that often don't get
the mic and giving the mic to them so
the fact that you guys tuned in means
the world anyways again thank you be
good to each other out there rock and
roll